These scars we have make us who we are
but if I could just go back somehow
I could save my mom could save your
parents you could also destroy everything
I completely broke the universe you changed the
past and you changed the future
who the hell are you
I'm Batman
no matter what we do we're not
going to be able to fix this
no
nobody dies
what are you doing our
kids are gonna want to see this
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie there's
a brand new Flash trailer with a bunch more
Batman so we'll break it all down also
explain Flashpoint Batman too because
they've obviously changed some things from
the comics but there's a lot of references
to the original Flashpoint Comics too during
that story they do a lot of really interesting
things with the Mythos because of the alternate
timeline flash creates always creating amazing
things by messing up the timeline both on the
Flash TV show and during The Flash movie now
I do this that original flash meme from way back
in the first couple seasons is going to last to
the heat death of the universe like it's just so
perfect in present day sure is a nice timeline be
ashamed of someone messed it up if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I know there's a lot of questions
about what's happening with the Flash TV show too
with Grant Gustin flash because this basically in
its last couple of episodes ever it will have its
serious finale in a couple weeks basically
bringing back all the biggest villains for
the last couple of episodes and paying off some
long-running fan theories with some characters
like cobalt blue too that people have had
since the very beginning of the show but at the
beginning of the new trailer you see a much longer
version of Ben Affleck's Batman at the beginning
of the movie earlier in the movie on his new bad
cycle taking down these criminals in Gotham City
it's meant to be just like another save another
date for Batman doing his thing it's their way
of showing you what's happening after the events
of the Justice League Snyder cut like life has
continued Batman is just still being Batman doing
his thing every day in Gotham the difference with
this scene is that it's actually happening in
the middle of the day because usually when you
see Batman and Gotham City taking down criminals
it's happening in the middle of the night the
version of the bat cycle that they had during The
Flash movie is like a slightly different upgraded
version of an idea that Zack Snyder had for his
bat cycle during Batman v Superman in the Justice
League movie I think they would have eventually
done it during the Justice League movie but the
idea is that Zack Snyder had all this concept
art that they didn't wind up using during Batman
v Superman when they introduced his version of
Batman he has some pretty cool technology during
Batman v Superman but was really during Justice
League when he was going to ramp that way up like
the new version of the bad copter here which is
basically a jet it was going to be the same thing
with his bad cycle so the version in the movie
here has that double wheel in front in the wheel
and back but the versions of Zack Snyder was going
to go with was actually based on that same jet
technology so there were no wheels it's hovered
in the air basically you can let me know which
version you think is cooler like the jet version
of the bat cycle or the more traditional looking
one that they used in the actual movie he's having
a conversation with the flash about the whole
concept of Flashpoint where he's trying to tell
him the that the Flash's parents died and Thomas
and Martha went like his own Batman's parents died
in the trauma of what happened forged them into
what they are today it helped make them better
even though the fact that their parents died is
a terrible thing while they're cutting scenes of
Flash in his Flash costume back in his childhood
room this is after a Flashpoint happens obviously
after he goes back in time and goes back into the
younger Barry Allen's room it seems like there
are a couple different parts of the movie they
added together where the flash is coming up with
the idea to go back in time like if I could just
go back in time I could fix everything I could
save my parents I could save your parents as
he's talking to Batman in a completely different
scene in Ben Affleck's Batman's trying to tell
him hell no don't do that you could destroy
everything because Batman's older wiser and
even though it might not completely seem like it
Batman in The Flash actually have a long history
of working together because they're both basically
crime scene detectives like Batman is the world's
greatest detective in the flash is a forensic
investigator working with the Central City Police
Department so they both kind of do similar things
they they actually explored this during the comic
during the button crossover where they're actually
meeting and talking about detective work together
trying to figure out what's going on with the
Watchman button so Batman is meant to be very
intelligent in fact he is the person who created
the Flash's ring from the comics that's based
on the way that it works in the comics obviously
slightly different origin story made from nanotech
in present day as opposed to nanotech from the
future but this Ben Affleck Batman is smart
enough to know how to design that so he also has
a rudimentary understanding of quantum physics and
how time works like what happens when you actually
try to change the timeline the short answer is
that nothing good winds up happening and this
is where we get to the idea of Flashpoint Batman
because they're doing a couple different things
with the concept during the movie in the original
story Flashpoint Batman essentially winds up being
Thomas Wayne who's just dead I watched him die
my God he's the one who died that night in the
alley Bruce died and you lived you're his father
you're Thomas Wayne because in the trailer when
he's talking about saving Batman's parents like I
could save your parents in Crime Alley from dying
he actually does kind of wind up doing that during
the original Flashpoint but not intentionally
when he does wind up changing the timeline it also
affects Batman's origin story and in that version
of events in Crime Alley he winds up being the one
who gets killed by Joe Chill in Thomas and Martha
Wayne wind up Surviving and just like the event
traumatized Batman and drove him to become the
Batman character in the future the cape and cow a
version that happens to Thomas and Martha Wayne
but it's a much darker version Thomas Wayne's
Flashpoint Batman uses guns all the time kills
villains all the time and is way more hardcore
way darker there's been a bunch of concept art
of Jeffrey Dean Morgan obviously because he is
the Thomas Wayne of Ben Affleck's Batman Universe
Lauren Cohan played his mother Martha Wayne during
Batman v Superman there's also been concept art
of the flashpoint version of her character and in
Flashpoint Martha Wayne becomes Flashpoint Joker
which arguably I think is a little little bit
darker even though Jeffrey Dean Morgan would be
like the Negan version of Batman to make a Walking
Dead reference the funny connection about that too
is there's been all these Easter eggs for him on
the boys TV show which is kind of like a DC parody
with the Justice League the seven homelander and
concept art of him is the tech Knight character
which is sort of an amalgam version of Batman and
the Iron Man character from the Marvel Universe
he'd be amazing in any of the roles because both
versions of those characters like Flashpoint
Batman as well as the tech Knight character are
just totally messed up very cool in messed up ways
in their own way but in completely different ways
like Flashpoint Batman is definitely dark just
really hardcore but if you think the boys TV show
has gone over the top with how crazy it gets how
crazy some of the things the characters do are the
things that technite does in the comics are Way
Beyond that way more messed up within the context
of this movie they're basically giving all that
Jeffrey Dean Morgan Thomas Wayne Flashpoint Batman
story to Michael Keaton's Batman Michael Keaton
is basically the flashpoint Batman but obviously
complete Different Twist on the character because
it's the normal version of his Batman just later
in his timeline like he's a much older version
of his character from the original Batman 1989
and Batman Returns movies as opposed to this
version of The Flash saving Batman's parents
or any version of Batman's parents but this is one
of the ideas why Flashpoint fundamentally is a big
Batman story for different versions of Batman
because both The Flash and Batman lost their
parents in tragic accidents so the idea is they
both have a lot in common also fundamentally they
are both detectives so to speak so there's just
a lot of things in common between the characters
which is why it's weird that you don't see them
working together more in the movies they kind
of started to do that during the Justice League
Snyder cup but obviously for movie franchise like
regular movie reasons they wanted to establish
the characters on their own because obviously
it was still all relatively brand new but in
all the Justice League sequels that Zack Snyder
playing like Justice League 2 Justice League three
a lot of their story is tied up together like the
whole idea with flash time traveling Batman gets
into a lot of that like you see in that distant
nightmare future sure both of them are working
together still Batman is trying to help Flash
and Cyborg try to figure out time travel so that
they can save this version of reality I'm sure
there's going to be a lot of questions about how
time travel Works inside the DC Universe because
obviously they're using this movie and the whole
concept of Flashpoint to reboot into James Gunn DC
chapter 1 Gods and Monsters this was a big thing
when Avengers end game came out and they had the
big time travel Heist because the Marvel people
had their own explanation for how time travel
worked how timelines worked and now that's like
a whole big thing with the Multiverse all the
different timelines in the variants of Kang
the interesting thing they've done in the DC
Universe with The Flash movie is they've actually
drawn things a little bit closer by changing the
original Flashpoint story they've changed their
explanation for how time travel works and it's
actually a little bit closer to the way that
Marvel explains time travel now whereas in the
original Flashpoint comic book the explanation
for time travel was much simpler but The Flash
movie is actually going with more of a Marvel
explanation where the flash causes Flashpoint
but what he's doing is he causes the version
of hyper time which is a DC concept where a
bunch of different timelines a bunch of different
possibilities start overlapping with each other
all of reality kind of starts to blend together
and get completely messed up so the whole idea
is that he could theoretically destroy everything
in the Multiverse if he continues to make it worse
and it sounds like that's part of his fight with
the dark version of flash during the movie which
is like the younger version of himself who goes
off the rails like you see them yelling at each
other nobody dies with the younger version of
himself just completely unwilling to accept the
idea that his mother does have to die there will
be some Henry Cavill Superman scenes during this
so he's not completely out of the movie but all
the scenes you see with this version of Supergirl
are basically a version of Flashpoint Superman
they're just giving the story to Supergirl instead
their story plays out pretty much the same way
like he winds up being a much stabbier version
of Superman because the military kept him captive
underground for so long even though it is really
cool that Michael Keaton Batman is coming back
as his version for this movie it would have been
cool to see Jeff Dean Morgan is the version of
Flashpoint Batman he said many times that he is
totally willing to come back and they might have
actually thought about it at one point before they
got Michael Keaton on board for this let me know
in the comments if they do wind up doing Jeffrey
Dean Morgan as a version of Flashpoint Batman at
some point in the future how do you want them to
do the character because they did say that they
might wind up doing the flash shoot like a flash
sequel movie just depending on what happens
with this movie even James Gunn was asked at
the Guardians of the Galaxy Premiere what's going
to happen with the future of the flash franchise
and he's like well we're just kind of waiting
and seeing what happens Ben Affleck actually
joked recently on a podcast about how he felt like
this version of Batman that he did in this movie
was the best version ever and how it actually
made him want to come back a little bit like
I know I said I was out and I wasn't doing any
more Batman but I was so perfect in this movie
I kind of want to come back a little bit maybe
you can click here to listen to him talk about
that it's actually pretty funny I don't think
that he'll actually come back that much but I
think the idea is that Never Say Never the door is
always open and click here for my Guardians of the
guy Galaxy 3 post credit scene video and full
breakdown in Easter eggs for the entire movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!